79 of America's millionaires airtight
research data not a feeling not a
political agenda not your broke
brother-in-law's opinion at Thanksgiving
not how he feels about rich people none
of this data 79 inherited precisely zero
wow 8 out of ten five percent more
inherited a small amount like fifteen
hundred dollars or five thousand dollars
mathematically could not have possibly
made them a millionaire another five
percent inherited substantial money like
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
dollars after they were already
millionaires so five and five and
seventy nine we're at 89
9 out of ten of America's millionaires
did not become millionaires because of
an inheritance wow